our next presenter began her career at
the tottering age of five when Orson
Welles put her before the camera and to
Mars forever a prophetic title she's
been a star ever since with the
sensitive Jimmy Dean in rebel without a
cause the beloved Rosalind Russell and
gypsy singing dancing in West Side Story
and playing the role of Carol and Bob
and Carol and Ted and Alice here is
Natalie Wood
you look beautiful tonight not even
prettier than when we did gypsy were you
in gypsy yeah don't you remember I did
the body makeup for the strippers yeah
I'm here to present the costume design
award a costume is anything you wear on
stage from a fig leaf to a wedding gown
and what you were in the movies
is designed by some of the nicest and
most unflappable people in our community
I know cuz they've done wonderful things
for me this year's nominees are Florence
Platz for a little night music her gowns
will be worn tonight by Cyd Charisse and
Stockard Channing
Eirene sheriff for the other side of
midnight
Camila's barb and Priscilla Barnes are
wearing the sheriff's designs
Edith Head and Burton Miller for Airport
77 Eleanor Parker and Deborah Ruffin
will show their fashions to you
Emperor filbert for Julia
Michelle Lee and Karen black are dressed
in her creations
John Malo for Star Wars Susan George
where's his intergalactic concept and
Kermit eller where's the Darth Vader
costume
is John Malo
for Star Wars
the question from starwars are really
not so much costumes as bit of plumbing
and general automobile engineering
anyway my thanks to George and Gary and
particularly to the wardrobe department
especially Ron Beck and to all of you
for giving me this very happy tribute
thank you very much